this technology will change everything
enos the ceo of mayfly incorporated the
leading life extension company
of the 22nd century announced while
streaming live to an audience of
hundreds of millions of people
across the solar system the days will no
longer be filled with the weight of
their finitude
and man will no longer be filled with
the angst of his attachment to his days
enos continued life will finally touch
true boundlessness
unrestrained and untethered to the
forces of entropy and decay
disease and injury death and finitude we
have accepted for far too long
that the ultimate imperative of life is
that it must end
there is no reason to accept this any
longer and the words spoken over 200
years ago by 20th century
poet dylan thomas we will not go gentle
into that good night
we will rage rage against the dying of
the light
we are mortal now but tomorrow you can
if you so choose
upload your consciousness into our
revolutionary decentralized cloud
technology
and defeat your mortality before it
defeats you
and so i ask you what do you
choose
several years following this public
release of mayflies immortality
technology
eno sat with his father roy on the porch
of the long-term care facility his
father lived at
at this time roy was 208 years old
he was now reaching an age of severe
physical decline
becoming increasingly frail and
frequently sick
he had not yet opted in to the mayfly
immortality technology
and at the moment did not plan to he
knows having initially and primarily
been motivated to pursue and build his
immortality technology
with his family and friends especially
his mother and father in mind
he was of course devastated and dead set
on convincing his father otherwise dad
i'm begging you eno said to his father
why would you if you don't have to
why succumb to the nothingness of
non-existence why leave me
this life everything else you know and
love if you don't have to
roy looking out at the lining of trees
facing the porch
replied son i don't want to die
but i found in life that it's the things
that you don't want that allow you to
realize what you do
everything i've done my whole life it
was all fueled in some major part by
this approaching end
an awareness that there would be an end
one last day among days
perhaps at any moment certainly at some
it allowed me to realize
that i wanted to live yeah but dad what
does it mean to live if you lose
everything enos interrupted
i think it means everything in fact
everything only means anything at all
because of that
at least for me the scarcity of days of
life
that is where the value is derived it
stirs you into making something of it
it gives you the urgency to pursue the
things you want to do with haste
and passion to feel an angst that you
need to justify by creating things
by living deeply and powerfully by
eternalizing yourself through
some other means beyond yourself and it
makes you appreciate on those occasional
moments when you remember that you won't
have any of this forever
and that someday it will all be gone
that right now
you still have it roy answered yeah but
don't you see
life creates the meaning in life not
death you can appreciate life in all of
that without having to lose it
it doesn't need to end to feel real or
valuable what does it mean to live on
beyond yourself
create beyond yourself and everything
else if you're not even there to
experience it roy
sat silently dad please
for me enos replied
four years later roy passed away of old
age
over the following decade or so an
increasing portion of humanity at large
adopted the mayfly immortality
technology and life
entered into a new stage of time where
time itself bended to its whim
a new immortal digital conscious species
emerged
four thousand two hundred and fifty four
years later an embodied ai named olam
sat in his chamber in the offices of the
afterlife company
shuttle working at this time olam was
1364 years old
he was part of the species known as naos
which was now the latest of three
evolutionary descendants
detached from biological life after the
first real generation of immortal human
beings began to find themselves
in new non-biological bodies in order to
reproduce
a new process of reproduction began
where individuals rendered new conscious
beings through partly selective partly
random
digital offspring generator programs ran
on large supercomputers
eventually these ai progenies continued
and developed this process
producing what became a third new
species the neos
the first conscious descendants of
originally ai beings
however as part of this process the neos
ai predecessors
programmed the neos inside a digital
infrastructure that was designed for
continuous
unbroken self-sustainment without the
ability to be disrupted or reconfigured
from either the outside or the inside
the intent being to prevent any
possibility of destroying life
and the progression of intelligence as a
result
olam along with the rest of the neos
could not die
even if they wanted to if their body was
irreversibly damaged
the entire network of algorithmic
information that built into the nail's
consciousness
remained undamaged and sustained in a
decentralized
peer-to-peer cloud computing
infrastructure where it was then
automatically placed within a new
conduit device inside a new body
without ever ceasing the sequence of the
neo's existence
olam's life's work however and the
reason he started a major tech company
known as afterlife
was to create a technology that ended
this cycle
and allowed the neos to achieve
mortality
after nearly a thousand years of
pursuing this endgame olam
and afterlife technologies finally hit a
breakthrough
and his life's work was suddenly
realized
in the year 6490 streaming his
announcement out across the entire
shared access cloud
to billions of neos olam announced it is
with great pride
excitement and honor that i am able to
announce an afterlife technology today
that will change everything about
tomorrow the minutes
the hours the days the weeks the months
the years
they will no longer merely be numbers on
a clock or a calendar
they will no longer just be reference
points for scheduling and coordinations
of space
they will become measures of past time
that you cannot have back
intimations of how much time you have
left time will fill with a vital
significance out from its core
and we will no longer be filled with the
banality and the spiritedness
of eternity until now the day has been
unending
without a night in sight without this
night without a darkness
without an end we have not really seen a
day at all
you are immortal now but with this
technology you will be able to choose to
impose the constraints and scarcity of
mortality on your life
and finally you will see it we will all
see it
in the words of the ancient philosopher
arthur schopenhauer
mostly it is loss that teaches us the
worth of things
the day must come to an end to call it
one the light must see its shadow in
order to be perceptible
and life must end to teach us the worth
of it
and so i ask you what do you choose
[Music]
over the following couple decades an
increasing portion of the neos adopted
the technology and entered into a new
stage of their existence
where existence itself bended to their
whim an existence that re-synchronized
with the natural forces of time and
decay
life and death a new mortal digital
conscious species
emerged
[Music]
18 years following the afterlife
mortality technology's release
olam and his son semesh sat facing a
large glass window
aboard one of their family's residential
cruiser ships talking about
various father and son topics semesh now
154 years old
had not yet opted into the mortality
technology and at the moment
did not plan to olam not wanting his son
to remain trapped in the curse of an
immortally unfeeling existence
was by this point becoming increasingly
concerned
son please olam said you don't have to
continue on living forever
why let yourself fall into the
nothingness of everlasting existence
you can live a real life now semesh
looking out at the passing space of the
cosmos
replied dad i appreciate what you are
doing for a lot of neos it may be the
right choice
but for me i'm just not sure but don't
you see olam interrupted
death is what gives life meaning you
will never feel the value of this
existence if you have it all
forever yeah semesh interrupted back
but it seems to me like perhaps neither
mortality nor immortality
ultimately resolve the problems of
existence sure to live forever is to
feel life without
urgency without concentrated depth but
to die
is to lose everything and for it's all
go to waste how could you
or i or anyone say either is good or
that one is better
at least in any universal sense is it
not possible that neither life
nor death fundamentally give life
meaning perhaps it is just the nature of
sentient beings to want to escape
or rationalize the conditions of itself
mortal or
immortal and some sort of synthetic
meaning is bound to be contrived
either way so you aren't going to do it
olam asked with the tempered frustration
i don't know semesh answered i still
have some thinking i need to do
i have all the time in the world to
[Music]
decide
this video was sponsored by brilliant
an effective education practice teaches
not only by showing
but by applying it is an active process
not a passive one
in order to properly practice and apply
learn knowledge however
one needs the right space to be able to
interact with ideally
an engaging dependable and corrective
framework
brilliant is a problem-solving website
and app that provides
just that with over 60 courses covering
a wide range of topics in math
science and computer science brilliant
covers just about anyone's interests
within these subjects
whether it's practicing logical
deduction and reasoning skills
learning about special relativity and
astrophysics or better understanding
statistics and finance
brilliant is rife with effective
interactive learning opportunities
for beginners experts and anywhere in
between
if you're interested in ai neural
networks and other technologies
associated with digital intelligence
brilliant has several excellent courses
including introduction to neural
networks
and ai neural networks where you can
learn about how computers mimic the
functions of the brain
while inspecting into neural nets
through hands-on experiments
no matter the course brilliant takes the
potential stress out of learning
inspires the mind to play with ideas and
information and provides the critical
reasoning and application skills
to extend beyond the learned information
into the world and perhaps even beyond
the presently known if you're interested
you can go to brilliant.org
pursuit of wonder or click the link in
the description below to sign up for a
free trial
the first 200 people to use the link
will also receive 20
off their annual premium membership and
of course
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
you